SALMA HAYEK
Oh my God, I have so many.
Does it have to be three?
KUMAIL NANJIANI
The heart emoji, the shades emoji,
and then the strong arm one.
LIA MCHUGH
The old lady emoji, the shushing emoji,
and the robot emoji.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
The smiley face with the little
sweat drop at the side,
eyes-rolled-up emoji, the flowers emoji?
PHASTOS
I'm sure that was a lot of fun for you.
THENA
It was.
LAUREN RIDLOFF (in sign language)
The running woman emoji.
The book emoji.
And a French fries emoji.
GEMMA CHAN
Beer emoji, the sleeping emoji,
and the kind of grimacing emoji.
PHASTOS
You know what's never saved the planet?
Your sarcasm.
SALMA HAYEK
Only three emojis. I could do 20 emojis.
DON LEE
Heart, biceps, and fist emojis.
BARRY KEOGHAN
The Irish flag emoji,
shamrock emoji, and wolf emoji.
SALMA HAYEK
There is one that is kind of, like,
a ball of fire, a horse,
and, uh... a volcano.
AJAK
It is time.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Marvel Studios' Eternals
is in theaters November 5th.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Book your tickets today.